[Music]
all right thank you very good crowd out
here tonight so thanks everybody come in
lots of your faces which is awesome
today we're doing part six of the semi
slob series that we're on we're doing
the complete semi slob so we're about
halfway done with the series so I
appreciate everybody that's been
following along with the whole series
here
it's going to be it's been a lot of fun
and it's we got a lot more good stuff
coming we're trying to film so hopefully
this is being recorded
because Ben Simon isn't here so we got
Danny Machuca behind the camera so
hopefully everything's going all right
and you guys get to see this on YouTube
otherwise we're doing the same class
next week I guess that's that's the deal
okay but we're going to get right to it
so Danny's going to pan slightly to the
right and then we're gonna get get
started here on the board so we are
looking at the semi slob so we're going
to get to our main position here where
we got our our little triangle the semi
Slav and for the past several weeks
we've been focused only on the movie
three however tonight we're going to for
the first time have a look at some of
the even sharper lines with Bishop to g5
now this is probably the most natural
move in the position because you want to
get your bishop outside of the pawn
chain so already you know very normal
move and if black doesn't do anything
like we just make some legal move when
that white plays III the c-4 pawn is
protected and everything is normal so
white here would just get everything
that he wants so the onus kind of is on
black to do something now if you had to
create some problems or try to show that
white can't do this and if he's going to
do that he's got to do it now so tonight
we're going to begin focusing on the
move D take c4 the other move that we're
going to cover later is h6 and this can
lead to the moscow's or the anti Moscow
so we'll look at those with you know
we'll look at if they capture and if
they go back in the future of this
series but tonight we're going to focus
on taking the pawn on c4
okay and this leads to some of the
sharpest and most complicated positions
in all of chess and I've been asked that
a lot like people ask me you know what
is the most complicated opening in all
of chess and I always say the bottleneck
variation of the semi Slav so we're
going to look at some pretty crazy stuff
in the next couple of weeks here so
what's the point black is going to try
to hold on to this pawn but now white
almost always gets a huge center with
the move efore and black protects his
pawn we're going to look at a lot of
sidelines today so we're not going to
get to the main line of the bottleneck
tonight so we will come back I kind of
want to go through it so we can all see
it just so we know it what we're looking
at here tonight we will come back and
we'll look at the positional move a fork
let's say so let's take on c4 c4 and we
protect our pond and now after e5 it
looks like black may have blundered but
this is in fact alright so right we is
attacking our night and our night is pin
so we can't move our night and there's a
lot of people in here so I guess I'll
just ask we'll start off with a simple
question what move does black have to
play h6 yeah so you have to play the
move h6 so if you take mine I take your
Bishop and after you go back we still
need to break this pin so we have to
play g5 okay and now white almost always
plays this very interesting sacrifice
and we will come back to this position
but we'll just show the main line with H
takes there also exists this very
interesting yet very dubious option but
has a lot of lot of venom and there's a
lot of potential for a black or white to
go wrong if he doesn't know what he's
doing
so you're kind of taking a gamble if you
play that way we'll have a look at it
but after you take so he gave up a piece
but you'll notice that black is going to
get the piece back because this Knight
can't really move away and this Queen
ever moves away then we'll take the
knight so the main line is Knight B to
d7 we will also look at tonight this
will be our the third thing
we look at perhaps the most natural move
you just break the pin with the bishop
and you know you don't lose a pawn that
way we'll come back and so we're look at
the main line just for a second white
likes to put his bishop on this nice
diagonal okay it's so something like
this is going to be the focus of our
lectures in the future and in here what
usually plays Knight a four but we'll
also look at this very interesting
option rook to be one in the next class
so we'll focus more on that later but I
just give you an idea so you can see
that it gets kind of crazy stuff is
pinned and everything is it's sort of
wild in these variations in at least
isn't very complicated and interesting
you know positions that you get pawn
structures you don't get in any other
openings okay but we're going to return
here to when we just took on c4 and I
want to look just for a second at the
move a4 which seems like a very tempting
option but this doesn't give white any
real advantage so there's actually a
couple ways that black can equalize in
this position so it's not as popular but
it's actually been played at the top
level pretty recently in the last thing
filled cup we saw it we're also going to
see a gameplay in 2014
between some pretty decent players that
played this way so Bishop to b4 is you
know the most normal move you can play
after a four I just want to show one
games you can get kind of an idea of how
this is and this is probably the most
positional type of game that we're going
to see we're going to see wild crazy
tactics but the a4 lines are a lot more
positional and in the game way you
eavers magnus carlsen from nice 2009
carlson actually got a favorable pawn
structure right here right out of the
opening by taking on c3 and what's funny
about this position is that the most
popular move is b5 however none of the
top players have played it which is
something that happens sometimes you
look in the database every all the top
players are either taking the knight or
playing Queen to a5
which is something interesting when
you're looking in a database it'll show
like the most popular moves but then if
you actually look at who the best
players are that are doing it normally
you would expect that the opening theory
would be your best try for an advantage
but in this case the super elite don't
agree with the average joe's okay and
now queen a5 so we got some pressure
b5 so notice now if I take here this
would be a big blunder because I can
retreat get out of check and then your
knight is also hanging also your queen
sort of stuck okay so after in the game
after Knight to you 584 I'm the bishop
retreated to d2 and what I like about
this game is it's a very typical Carlsen
game where he doesn't get too much but
you'll notice okay he has a nice d5
square for his pieces and he doesn't
really try he doesn't have to try too
hard to give a very big advantage and it
looks like he didn't really do anything
in this game and he just slowly slowly
slowly outplayed his opponent so in this
game he centralized his Queen his plan
going forward is to play C five and then
one of his pieces can come to the c6
square so we'll see that happen white
played a5 one of the ideas is to prevent
black from playing b5 because now I can
take on Poisson
also after c5 which was played it gives
us the option of Queen a4 okay and we'll
get through this game kind of quickly
because you know it's the most boring of
all the games we're going to look at
today so he just traded Queens and put
his Bishop on c6 and you know there's
not much really for either side maybe
blacks a little bit better but it's not
too much but this is the kind of
position Carlsen is really good at he
can make this yeah so Carlson is black
here you know he just slate all I need
is you know a couple squares that's all
I need I got some tension in the center
it brings another night out
now the root comes to c1 so black has
been waiting because maybe I want to
make sure I get the two bishops away
from you so he's been thinking okay
maybe I'll just take this guy
whenever you protect this pawn so now
this pawn is finally protected so
White's next move is going to be Bishop
to e3 so it's kind of tempting to take
the bishop now well you can but he
decided to do some other stuff that was
also really good for him
so instead of you know capitalizing on
that advantage he decided to play for
another advantage so that's why he's the
best after king e7 and the bishop moved
away so he left the bishop move away
played the move b5 now taking on Besant
will really make much sense if I you
know get the a file for myself if you
have to you take it and then I get the a
file that's going to be good for me so
he just dropped back to D 3 and C 4 was
played I'm not really too worried about
you giving me your Bishop so the bishop
went back and you'll notice now there's
some slight discord ination in the white
camp here so some of these guys are just
slightly awkward and black has some very
nice pieces we have a chance to continue
to undermine the center going forward
and what black always had just a
slightly better position and it just led
to a slight initiative which is just
enough for Carlsen and now in this
position you know there's four ways to
take back which is really hard
unless you're magnus carlsen then you'll
play the best way so he went here and
one point is you know this Knight
actually might be better going to d5
okay and so this happened in 95 so okay
black has just done well to coordinate
his pieces a little bit better than his
opponent f3 was played so that nothing
ever happens here and here he took and
black is the first one to get to the
open file and so it's not much this
isn't this isn't huge you know pewter
will say like very close to zero zero
zero you know
and you know you'd expect over the next
couple moves you know maybe we're all
going to put our rooks on the D file
we're going to trade all the pieces
we're going to agree to a draw also I
believe this was a blindfold game it's
probably a rapid blindfold game so so
that should be mentioned which is
another reason you know he's not doing
anything overly complicated but the
mistake that was made in the game coming
up
what kind of make us think you know how
they did not calculate that right well
he probably wasn't looking and here
white should just simply defend this
pawn that was attacked and then
everything's equal however he played the
move Bishop to e4 which is the mistake
they cost the game yeah and the eyes the
audience is pointing out you can just
take the pawn so he must have thought
that you can't do this
white thought he had a trick but trick
doesn't work yes so yeah he went King to
d4 and said hahaha your bishops hanging
you can't go back if you take my bishop
I take your rook but Carlsen found the
only move that is you know probably wins
what did black play in this position so
it's tough you got a guy play the best
move here this is what white must have
overlooked rip d8 is interesting but
your rook is hanging yeah
now you want to sacrifice in exchange
but now I'm up in exchange no yet better
king of six yeah king of six was played
and okay anyone here yeah right so this
is what he must have overlooked because
if here rook d8 and you can block either
way let's block this way because it
because the maid is funnier so this is
what white must have overlooked and so
he lost upon no big deal unless you're
playing world champion and I just grind
you down
so instead rook d1 and now he just saves
his Bishop and okay the rest of this was
was very technical and we've gone
slightly beyond the openings we're gonna
try to get through it quickly well
they're not looking so yeah it's it's
easy to make these mistakes when you're
not looking so they traded lots of stuff
and it's it's not like a huge amount
it's just one pond which so maybe and
it's a rook endgame you know sometimes
you can draw those well black had a
pretty nice plan here his he doesn't
want his rook to be tied up here his
rook needs to you know go do stuff so he
brought his king over here you know
white tries to push his majority okay
and so all that happened and we protect
here
and he just has a simple plan of going
and getting this guy which was enough so
with some super Grandmaster technique
he was able to just go get all these
guys up here and white resigned so right
so a super positional approach with the
move a four and it's it's interesting
that I can actually get and we all
started to the opening just a pawn
structure was just a little bit better
for black here in this position because
after I feel there after we take we can
kind of force you to play e5 and let's
you know we need
you just need to remember that okay you
play c5 get your Bishop into the game
and I can come into the game and Carlsen
just had a great game make sure you
Queens in the middle so that's the most
positional line that we're going to look
at tonight and I mean it's thought to
not really give an advantage of white
wants to to play for the biggest
advantage theoretically possible in this
position you should play e4 so now it
doesn't make any sense to like break
this pin because we can take out c4 we
can play you five so we protect our pond
that was the whole point of our play and
now e5
okay so black plays h6 got to break the
pin maintain the pin got to break the
pin and we sacrifice now again the main
move is to take the knight but I just
want to test the audience a little bit
with a very very interesting very
suspicious sort of a gambit here this is
the Ella torts of variation it's a
pretty much loses by force but if you've
never seen this I think you'll have a
lot of difficulty coming up with all the
right moves here so I do want to put the
audience to the test a little bit more
with this variation so so yeah white
wins yeah though it's very complicated
because blacks going to get a lot of
activity coming up it's going to happen
yeah cuz yeah you're going to win
material here
how does white win material Queen h5 so
I'm wondering if I can just actually
take this Queen Age 5
it's interesting I mean I guess I have
to do this and whatever the consequences
are do you have anything SML so if you
take my rook I take your bishop
yes on this position
I took your night because you didn't
yeah so in this in this position here
negative three probably does give way to
a very slight advantage so you actually
can play this way it's it's interesting
and if you don't wanna learn any theory
you can just do that and be like haha
I'm just a little bit better but some
people want to win and especially if
you're you know you're studying and
analyzing a variation that you might get
in the future and you can have a win you
should play the winning move ya Knight
takes f7 a revealed attack on the Queen
also we're attacking the rook on h8 so
the Queen is the most important so we
take the bishop and white takes the rook
however I want to take a look at a move
that's never been played before in this
position the move g3 and what's
interesting is when I was just analyzing
this and nobody's ever played this move
because it it loses for white so white
is flip the script but I think it's very
difficult to find the actual best most
accurate moves here so I'm going to try
to win quick and dirty with white even
by playing a losing move and I'm going
to test the audience just to see if you
can survive and it's just to give you an
idea that some of these variations get
incredibly tactical to get really
complex it's not easy so I just want to
put you guys to the test what would you
guys do if you were black in this
position
93 Xeon the move yeah okay now I assume
you would find the right moves if I
played one of these obvious ones
ah I'm gonna play the trickiest move and
now I'm going to challenge you to find
the best move now I don't want to talk
about the move that wins easily because
that's too easy I want to talk about the
best move because I think it's it's more
challenging and more technical and cool
and also
what is the most accurate move here for
black and at home you can pause if you
need more time
so Queenie Four Winds pretty easily
because then you trade the Queens and
then it's pretty easy but I want to
challenge you to play the most accurate
move no that's a good move
that's good move but play a better move
and you would only play that like so if
you didn't know this position you would
just trade the Queens and then win that
way but I'm only asking you guys to be
as strong as my engine was at home
that's all I'm asking it's queen takes
d4 yeah this is the move though did you
see this did you see this position I
just take back yeah awesome Bishop b4
that's the move that's the move pinning
the pond yeah which is just fantastic
and my favorite variation well first of
all give this variation the Machuca
variation that I showed to Dani black
actually here has a surprisingly strong
move and I'll give it away close rook f8
is close castle yeah and then yeah
Black's crushing it he's doing fantastic
yeah cap just Castle um so that moves
awesome I think my favorite computer
line though the computer wants me to go
here which now it looks scary because it
like goes here he doesn't care about
nothing it goes here and then just
laughs hmm just laughing at you and in
black wins yeah you got to check me a
lot I should be really scared but I'm
not and then you know so that's the sort
of really complicated stuff now g3 has
never been played but now it's on the
internet so you know people could start
playing
if you don't want a winning position and
you want to try to win really quick
instead of patiently winning a winning
position you can try g3 here but ok
let's take on h8 so we didn't play g3
and now black plays Bishop to b4 and so
notice how active I am you know my queen
Knight and Bishop they're all getting
pretty close
you got some threats right here and over
the next couple moves Black has a couple
different ways to try to get all of his
pieces into the attack
well I'm threatening c3 so the most
natural move here is the best just
defend with the rook and now two
different moves have been tried in this
position Queen e4 which is probably
objectively the best move and then c5
which the computer hates horrible but
probably gives you better practical
chances well because objectively it's a
very bad move okay that's why it hates
it because it defends right and then
it's like yeah horrible but if you're a
human and you played this variation
knowing that it's dubious it seems like
it's like a such a natural move right
I'm trying to break down your center now
I have this open for my bishop you know
my Knights going to come here with some
pressure and all the important squares
computer hates it because it just
defends right it's like a horrible I
just defend easy easy
yeah so we'll go over this but again I
just wanted to point out that the reason
you play this variation is not to play
you know exactly the most objective way
to play it you're playing Russian
roulette you're playing this way hoping
that white doesn't know the refutations
and then you just you can win quickly
because you get all this activity okay
it takes there
it looks good but in this line at least
white will get to castle and white
castles and it's there's still a lot of
room to go really wrong
yeah computer day I was like I defended
my household and you're not going to
have any checkmating attack because I
can defend against everything I mean it
looks it looks kind of scary because I
got these guys that might possibly come
in now just don't believe it
right because yeah there is nothing and
so here just this is easy enough for
white c5 was too slow yeah because yeah
a white just gets the castle plus cause
you a little bit more problems all right
let's try Queen to you for what would
you guys play in this position so if you
play Queen e2 and you unde offend your
deep on you're sort of justifying my
play a little bit now I got a pawn back
I got more pressure on c3 and if you
play Queen h5 I like just run away so
yeah we know we don't want to give them
that
yeah Bishop b2 yes so we're not worried
about you taking on g2 we would just
play Bishop f3 all right but what no and
so this is sort of the idea I'm just
going to ask you a lot of questions so
you can't Castle because Queen takes g2
what are you going to do so work g1 was
suggested I'm pretty sure they just run
away I don't know yeah I looked at this
I'm trying to remember so it might have
been queen h7 here and it said like
equal trying to remember I think this is
fine I think also doing nothing was fine
King d8 and C like doing nothing is also
fine you didn't really want to put your
rook there
he's probably equal but you have better
and where we want to totally refute
blacks play here yeah f3 the problem
with f3 is in a lot of these lines you
actually want to play Bishop to h5
that's usually a big thing you didn't
really want your pawn here so I can just
sneak in I can also play queen h7 in
that position well so still you can't
castle and I mean what do you do I'm
still going to take on g2 next what are
you what do you you know still looks
pretty dangerous
I don't know imagine nothing let me go
get your guy yeah but it yeah it's might
be okay for two for you for white but
you can do even better than this so
again we're trying to avoid playing
Moses we don't want to play we didn't
really want to play f3 wouldn't want to
block in our Bishop and we can do even
better
Brooksie - this was my big threat and if
here I have this move which is going to
be a recurring theme in these lines so
we've got to be careful yeah the best
move yeah and that's the point that's
why you play this as black because even
with an audience full of people Oh
even with not even full of people and we
got some pretty high rated people here
it's difficult that's why you play it as
black because you have to like and learn
all of this as white otherwise it's easy
to blunder it to an equal position and
it's easy to just lose because look at
all the stuff going on so we're kind of
seeing the problem our King can't really
go this way so that's not a very good
good way for him to escape so he's gonna
have to escape a different way so Queen
d2 is the move and this is the most
common move if here so what yeah okay
yeah audience got it so what um and now
you can check yeah you're going to win
the rook yeah so what yeah that's right
attitude we can just go here and yeah
then whites and so what and he laughs
and he's and then he goes on to win so
this is what you would need to know to
refute this and then you have to move
your queen one issue
so there's actually this haven't played
a couple times by humans and every human
makes this mistake and then you're
really lost so you have to play king -
Queen Gigi - because if you let me go
here there's bad stuff here the bad
stuff here and that's too much bad stuff
you gotta let me do that much bad stuff
on both diagonals
so this is already like totally crushing
it's a more severe threat in the
position was it rook h1 that's pretty
serious
yeah so yeah it's just yeah it's not
very good so you'd have to play here
which no humans have played and white is
winning so yes that's what you need to
know if you want to play this crazy
variation so we'll go back just to the
very very beginning here so Knight to d5
in this position the yellow towards that
variation very risky but you can also
win you know if you're trying to confuse
your opponent especially you know if
you're lower rated it's great weapon
because it's very difficult to figure
out if its first time you know something
you got to kind of know okay and I
didn't want to look at one more
variation so we'll just return to this
variation again we'll just see from the
very top Bishop to g5 we take on c4 they
get the big Center we hold on to our
pond they attack our Knight h6
break the pin they sacrifice okay and
this time we're not gonna play ninety
five we're going to take on g5 which is
the most common way and they take back
now if you play here which is the
mainline it's black that's actually
sacrificing a pond but in these
positions one thing that doesn't matter
is material everybody sex everything in
these kind of lines and they get to be
really crazy so we're going to see that
in the next couple of weeks so the fact
that this is your extra pawn doesn't
mean a whole lot but what if you play
the move Bishop to e7 because now I
break the pan and I'm not going to lose
upon and kind of for a long time I
thought this was the way that people
that don't really know this position
play because I've had people that you
know they don't know this is the most
natural move Bishop to e7 I'm not going
to win my pawn back because after you
take my knight I can take back but
there's actually quite a lot of venom
if black knows what he's doing and this
to is also a pretty great surprise
weapon but you do have to be prepared
to have nerves of steel if you want to
play this way as black as we're going to
see okay so we just took our pawn back
sounds great
and white could consider dropping his
bishop back which is not the most common
move but if you just compare the bishops
you might notice one is better than the
other and if you trade it might actually
be black that has some issues on the
dark squares blacks moved quite a lot of
pawns and a lot of dark squared
weaknesses you know maybe you can get
your knight in there but this is sort of
the starting point here okay in all
these lines we want to put our bishop on
this open diagonal and the most common
move here might surprise you Knight a
six you can also start with Bishop to b7
and then Knight a six and in these lines
the knights going to go to a six and not
to d7 and I'll explain why in a second
so after here here now in these lines
notice if your knight was here one of
the things is you're going to Castle so
there's if funny stuff happens on this
diagonal like like this which is not the
most common move we're going to look at
a different game Nakamura row neon that
was played here in st. Louis in 2014
with Knight to e4
so the professional choice but if Knight
to b5 you want to be able to like Castle
and then since you're not blocking in
your rook also if you were here then
they could play Knight to d6 but by not
blocking in your book you also have some
additional pressure here on the center
so that's why the knight is developed to
a6 okay let's look at this I mean went
on that seems like very very natural oh
you just blender it along that diagonal
how amateurish and so castling is a very
good move I don't look at it an
interesting move first I'm going to take
your knight
which also looks like a big blunder
because now I take on b7 and I'm forking
your pieces and I'm gonna challenge you
and you can pause at home
what did black have in mind so you have
to find a way and again these positions
are your computer's always going to say
everything's equal all these lines are a
draw but it's tough you have to know
stuff
yeah night before this is the move also
possible but not as good is rook to b8
and you can like trap this Bishop sort
of but even better is Knight to b4 and
this check is it yeah it's very brutal
check notice cross somewhere so for
example if you're too greedy this check
is not good for you so probably you have
to give up your queen here because if
you go here the best move is actually to
take right here
and yeah you know you don't have like a
lot of escaping and I'm doing
discoveries this is really really bad
for you
so how quickly that went awry so you
can't even take the rook okay so let's
say we just Castle okay now it's not
check if you Blaine exit e3 now we just
bring our broke in and we attack the
pawn inching in this position so it's
still very very complicated but black
does have is attacking possibilities so
immediately we're going to win this guy
you know we got some active pieces here
this guy is coming to a pretty good
Square uh-huh
so it's actually a very interesting and
really complicated way for black to play
so a very interesting line if you're
interested in looking at it let's look
at the more played line which is you
take my pawn I just Castle so now I got
some pressure here
you got to decide what to do with your
night now I want to look at three moves
in this position the most common human
move in this position is a four straw
there's just very quick draw perpetual
check excuse me there's also the
computer line that humans don't play and
then there's the line that humans would
play you know if they're like trying to
win and don't want to play the computer
line
the most common move in this position is
Queen to a four and then draw draw draw
zero zero zero okay we take check and we
get we get this draw and we repeat you
have to take the draw here with white
otherwise you lose and black has a move
here that's like so powerful the
computer announces mate like you put
this on thing and it's like you know
mate and fifty obviously so you have to
find one super powerful move here but if
you find it the engine throws up huge
numbers and then announces me
yeah Queen f3 you know it's not really
the hardest move and then White has to
give up his rook I think the best move
is like take here if you for example go
here there's threats actually think we
need four might be more accurate but
like this this leads to mate and this is
wherever your King goes this is going to
lead to like mate I'm gonna do some
stuff like this and then bloop so
there's me those such checkmates so I
have all these mating threats and also
you know Brooke the g1 doesn't help
because I'm taking on h2 so this is just
really bad and you know you're so bad
the computer like announces me which is
kind of surprising but uh so you have to
take the draw with white and okay
usually when you're playing an opening
is black and white wants to draw it's
fine I black so let's take a look at
some different options well the computer
its moves to take wine I have to take
on fine was cool now you should really
play King to be eight
if King to c7 which i think is very
tempting because you're protecting this
guy this guy is kind of trapped what's
going on
well white actually has a pretty
powerful maneuver that is really good
for him and this yeah this is just like
such a strong maneuver that I guess I
don't didn't put it in there but it's
just what do you do now you know if you
have to go back then we're taking on c6
and that didn't really work and if you
don't
let's just play some random move let
should take something Queen a5 is always
a super annoying move yeah that even if
Queen b6 side here King d7 castlelong
yeah yeah right so you can't really
block with your rook because your other
rooks hanging yeah it's brutal stuff
it's brutal stuff yeah the Queen a four
to a five is is really devastating okay
but King b8 alright you're going to take
on c6 I get it I get it
you know I basically have to take it
and now you have to find the right move
and it's the move you're always trying
to play in all of these this type of
positions 95 is interesting and it's on
the right track but I assume I can just
Castle here
so some it's on the right track but
there's a slight difference between this
move and this move
yeah 94 more accurate for a very very
interesting reason notice in this
position castling loses a bishop did you
notice that it's so night to be 4 so you
kind of got to move your bishop
but also you're facing this check
okay and then if they check here you've
got to worry about this guy
Bishop to f3 and Black has two bows one
good move is to take the pawn let's go
move but I'm going to play here a little
bit more forcing okay you go here I go
here and we've seen how powerful that
Queen can actually be on f3 and white
only has one move in this position so so
good luck I am on your rook I do have
this sort of idea castle yes that's
actually interesting yes you can't
really castle this way because of a
common tactical trick you just take on
h2 right and the point is if here here
so yeah very common tactical trick to
keep in mind so you can't castle you did
that before you sack the stuff where you
got made it that way he's acting right
that way that's pretty cool it's always
fun it's a fun one to do and it's it's
often overlooked all right so you got to
play the right move here these positions
are top
rook f1 is a mistake take on d4 and my
threat let me do nothing is to go here
here and just nothing you can really do
about it you know that's not it it's now
or never
what you gonna do King d2 wow what a
look for a Z crazy move alright go ahead
and run away your run yeah yeah you go
back you're look singing yeah yeah I
could nope can't run away with your King
that way can't go that way
can't do it Queen c4 which was right in
the other line taking your rook did you
have something in mind alright let me
just I mean I don't let me just be
really greedy and you think you got a
perpetual I think I'm gonna run away
yeah not evil is okay so now you can do
do better as white really yeah alright
this stuff that's why I'm asking you
look g1 Mario looper only move it that's
it and the point is you have the square
for your king you need to run the other
way just on the event of this you know
right you can you always you always can
run away and okay still complicated draw
and that's how a lot of these lines are
really really complicated it's always a
draw but you know good luck finding all
these games in a real game over the
board
oh yeah good luck yeah oh yeah only move
draws and yeah so these these positions
are crazy and okay I did want to show
one last line to move knight a3 which is
the only other human move the people
you know queen a4 was a draw yeah I play
Knight a3 seems good I'm gonna ream
still here I just grabbed your beep on
you're over there you know your castles
weakened I'm doing great
and it's true to a point I take here on
d4 main move is Queen e2 but night
before because and now these lines you
always play Knight to before from
castles and white maybe is better but
it's it's complicated and the computer
here says you only have like one move to
stay equal with white also very
difficult because it doesn't make any
sense but yeah here's like a guy go here
with your queen brilliant and then you
know I can in continues so but I mean
again it's just still a messy position
and that's what you're playing for you
know this is rec but I have some very
active pieces I got this Knight he's
looking pretty good you know this pawn
will eventually maybe go forward and
this guy is going to be good I got look
yeah Queen e1 computers like yep and
good job white you equalized again yeah
it looks ok I mean that looks looks like
a decent move but that's a supercomputer
level if you were only 3,300 rated you
would you know realize Queen e1 is the
better move and yet but I mean these are
always fun to check with engines because
I come up with such brilliant stuff that
you would like never come up with so I
hope I shared some of that with you guys
tonight
yeah and yeah so these are the kinds of
positions I hope you guys enjoy and play
with these with your computers because
they'll come up with some pretty
imaginative stuff which is also good for
your your chest trying to find some and
that's the whole point about the botnik
variation there's so many positions that
just don't really make sense to humans
that's why I tell everybody these are
the most complicated positions in chess
because no matter what you always come
up with like the craziest computer line
and it always laughs at you after your
game and it's like everything else could
have been better
you're the worst AHA puny mortal but
they come up with some some pretty great
stuff and so that's sort of the intro to
the botanique variation we're going to
cover them
lines next week so thanks everybody for
coming down to is a great class as
always hit like share subscribe and
we'll see you next week
[Music]
you
you
[Music]